موجز الاخبار من قناه الجزيره اهلا بكم
يواصل جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حصاره على
منطقه اريحا بعد مقتل مستوطن في اطلاق نار
نائب منطقه الاغوار ونشرت قوه الاحتلال
حواجز عسكريه في محيط المدينه وعززت
قواتها بحثا عن منفذي هجوم الاثنين
واعتقلت قوته الاحتلال ثمانيه فلسطينيين
على الاقل في بلده يعبد في جنين واخرين في
مخيم العروب في الخليل
قال الرئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي انما
سماها العمليات الارهابيه والاحداث
الاخيره كبدت اسرائيل ثمنا باهظا وان
الجيش يجري تحقيقا بشانها ويدرسها
واقل جونكير بمنسق لاتصالات الاستراتيجيه
بمجلس الامن القومي الامريكي للجزيره ان
الاحداث الكارثيه التي شهدتها الضفه
الغربيه تؤكد اهميه الالتزام بالتفاهمات
المعلنه في العقبات
عقد مجلس الامن الدولي جلسه مغلقه بحث
خلالها الاوضاع المتوتره في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله واتفق الاعضاء على
متابعه الوضع عن كتب وبحث سبل دعم الحوار
ووقف العنف
اقر قائد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه بان
الوضع في محيط مدينه باخمت متوتر للغايه
واشار الى ان ميليشيات فاجنر تستخدم
وحداتها الاكثر استعدادا لاختراق الدفاعات
الاوكرانيه ومحاصره المدينه
من جانبها قالت ميليشيا فاجنر انها تتقدم
على تخوم الشماليه لمدينه
غربي المدينه
على وقع تاييد الروسي للخطه الصينيه
للتسويه في اوكرانيا جدد الكريم القول ان
حل المساله الاوكرانيه على طاوله
المفاوضات امر وارد لكن الاولويه لتحقيق
الاهداف العسكريه
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انه لا يمكن
للصين ان تلعب دورا مزدوجا عبر تقديم
مقترحات للسلام بينما تؤجج الحرب في
اوكرانيا
فلا مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي لشؤون
شرق اسيا والمحيط الهادئ ان شركه الاقمار
الصناعيه
التي تخضع لعقوبات امريكيه وفرت صور اقمار
صناعيه لدعم فاجنر في عملياتها القتاليه
في اوكرانيا
ابهل البيت الابيض الهيئات الحكوميه
ثلاثين يوما للتاكد من ازاله وحظر تطبيق
تيك توك على اي من الاجهزه والانظمه
التابعه للحكومه الاتحاديه بسبب ما وصف
بمخاطر تطبيق المملوكي لشركه صينيه على
الامن القومي
في المقابل اتهمت الخارجيه الصينيه
الولايات المتحده باساءه استخدام مفهوم
الامن القومي
هذا ونقلت عن مصادر مطلعه ان اداره بايدن
تدرس الغاء تراخيص التصدير من الموردين
الامريكيين لشركه هواوي الصينيه للاتصالات
نقلت الصحيفه عن وزيره التجاره الامريكيه
قولها ان واشنطن تشتري اكثر من 90% من
الرقائق الالكترونيه المتقدمه من تايوان
وهي ثغره امن قومي لا يمكن الدفاع عنها
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]